ryan giggs the former manchester united  and wales footballer is to face a  retrial on domestic violence charges  that is a ruling from a judge at  manchester crown court that has just  been announced ryan giggs is to face a  retrial on domestic violence charges  you'll remember of course that uh his  most recent trial uh the judge  signed off the jurors after they were  unable to come up with even a majority  verdict now we've seen reporting that  suggests that if re-trial was to take  place speculation that it would not  happen until june next year we don't  have any information on that as to when  a retrial will take place but that is  the breaking news that's just come out  of manchester crown court the former  manchester united and wales footballer  ryan giggs is to face a re-trial on  domestic violence charges